if you came to my house we wouldn't have
passed potatoes I bestow the pardon on
mr. Jon Gruden yes I will thank God you
gave 71 million dollars to Alec Smith
[Music]
what up everybody welcome to citizen let
go is the wonderful Thanksgiving edition
Sims you're practically family at this
PO Happy Thanksgiving what did you bring
I brought nothing awesome I brought the
turkey oh that's great are you all
eating it are you a leg or a wing guys
I'm a breast guy okay a leg in a wing is
the same thing but no it's not the leg
is that and the wing is that I mean
they're basically the same what you mean
dark meat is it really this is a
meaningless debate that we will figure
out later but right now it is time to do
our pardons you've seen presidential
pardons where they forgive the turkey
and let it live another day we have some
people in the NFL that may need to be
pardoned
first one up oh look at this turkey Jon
Gruden ah are you willing to part in Jon
Gruden for trading Khalil Mack and
leading to what we're seeing right now
it oh I bestow the pardon on mr. Jon
Gruden yes I will I will give him the
pardon because I don't I think there was
more in play with the Khalil Mack
situation than what we know I do think
there was some financed whole story
hasn't come out yet his not call come
out now Herc Davis's check sir bouncing
exactly right well he's had a few issues
we know that but I'm giving him a pardon
for Khalil Mack okay it is man he's so
good come on Mack it's hard to get in
that part we got a double Turkey here so
you can pardon one you could part him
both on the right time Montgomery his
fumble in the Rams game Mike McCarthy
punting fourth and two against the
Seahawks both of these turkeys prevented
us from seeing Rodgers possibly going
the length of the field cook them well
done both of both of them I didn't put
one in the fryer and the other one in
the oven and make sure they're well done
yeah they're just keep them juice
there's no excuse for ty Montgomery
bringing the ball out in that situation
and cheating all of us including his own
team the Packers and not giving Aaron
Rodgers a chance to win it and then Mike
McCarthy with two of your best defensive
players not healthy and you just let up
drives of 77 and say do you think now
you're gonna stop them that no sorry
into the fryer I got one more for you
okay this is week two Oh
when after the Jaguars beat the Patriots
I have a clip for this Turk oh thank you
chalk it up they're gonna win the Super
Bowl how's Utah with the Jaguars with
their win over the Patriots I am going
to say in your defense I'm gonna part in
this turkey one because blank and Lefko
doesn't have any cash a to a thank you
but I'll be honest when the Jaguars beat
the crap out of the Patriots it wasn't
even that hot of a take no but boy have
they fallen off no how dare I have faith
in Blake bortles in that offense what
was I think you're gonna stand for
anything you should have known that was
great I know I know they have totally
fought but you're part yourself are Dhin
uh yeah I would pardon myself I would
yes I would thank you okay well are you
right about everything you can't Blake
bortles is not really a meaningless
debate we know what side you're on
yeah but we've been having a meaningless
debate right here in the bleacher report
office that you can bring to your
Thanksgiving dinner
it's about sides and we had to ask
Landon Collins mac and cheese or mashed
potatoes dented mac and cheese or mashed
potatoes I'm gonna go to Sims first well
it's it's mashed potatoes for mashed
potatoes yeah I'm subbing so he's making
I want you to understand this is a
cultural divide it is you even have
mashed potatoes and Thanksgiving not
that I recall
not even at the table I don't think so
do you ever have mac and cheese at your
Thanksgiving table now really I'm
fascinated by this because I love mac
and cheese but to me Thanksgiving with
the turkey and the gravy on top of the
mashed potatoes I couldn't fathom it not
being at a table 3 correct but what do
you think that I feel that like that
combination how you did that but mac and
cheese has to be there okay and then
Collins came to Adam left ghost
Thanksgiving dinner and I didn't have
mac and cheese would you be upset not
wouldn't be upset this is how you have
your household because if you came to my
house we wouldn't have passed potatoes
do you like mashed potatoes yeah I love
mashed potatoes okay would you be upset
a little show with it so with John show
your aggression I would like pause like
I'd be scooping I'd be like green beans
I have no filter Landon I'd be like to
your whole family I'd be like no match
for Tay toes what's going on here like
I'd say it would love these got to be
there
I'm Stefon Diggs and you're watching
Sims and local
hello and welcome to the greatest
stadium ever invented it is Jerry's
world in beautiful Arlington Texas I'm
Adam Lefko your trusted Dallas Cowboys
homer reporter and let's welcome in one
of the Sims haven't really taken a
chance to get the name I'm Chris thanks
good to meet you and he's representing
the Washington red I better not
oh you mean the team that's winning uh
top the NFC East right now how are you
doing in second place Ville
well we've won two in a row and
technically were the favorites to win
this division Chris whoa whoopty-doo
okay yeah we've lost Alex Smith his leg
broke like a turkey wishbone but we'll
be ok cold McCoy's here to save the day
he's actually every bit as good as Alex
Smith if not better Wow then thank God
you gave 71 million dollars to Alex
Smith by the way that was in guaranteed
money the future seems bleak Chris off
you shouldn't talk about the future
buddy it sounds like you're about to
back up the old truck to give 75 million
dollars to dak Prescott good luck with
that one you guys should be getting that
six Super Bowl anytime soon it's a
Brinks truck and I don't know if I
should be listening to personnel
decisions from a man that lets Sean
McVeigh walk and make Jay Gruden the
coach by the way Jay Gruden is the other
Groot and the one people really aren't
that interested in you had to bring up
Sean big bang huh have you heard about
our season ticket scandal I did am i
mean just parking one that was bad for
Brandon loiter Antoine Randall L those
signings were great nabbed Deion Sanders
or Albert Haynesworth
Wow let's just know this when we
eventually win the division yes I make a
promise to you that we're gonna lose
that first round of playoffs because
well we're averages for football in 2018
this year especially has been defined by
the past we're seeing quarterbacks
destroying records but we're also seeing
a number of teams protect their
quarterback really well right you study
the film every week all the teams and I
thought it would be cool to do the top
five offensive lines in the NFL fitting
and number one may surprise Thanksgiving
I mean the big boys the big fatties
nobody need more Turkey than them this
week I guarantee it I hope not I might
eat just as much
you're number five offensive line yes
who the Dallas Cowboys they fall into
five they have fallen to five they're
still awesome don't get me wrong I mean
they're capable of dominating in the run
game and doing things like that ever
since Marc Columbo took over that
position so much better they've moved
themselves up to five I feel like right
number four a surprise team out west
yeah I mean the Los Angeles chargers I
mean look what they're doing this year
they pass protect Phillip Rivers
phenomenal they have a run game that's
very multiple with Anthony Lin's run
game genius behind it but pull guards
inside outside zone they can do
everything it's a very good group number
three a lot of people might have this
offensive line at number one yeah
Indianapolis Colts here number three
team yes there no right yes I mean it
hasn't been the whole season it's really
just come together it's young guys but
this is like one of the most promising
groups for the day because you're number
one for a lot it could be number one by
the end of the season if they continue
to just keep Andrew Luck clean and blow
people off the line of scrimmage in the
run game number two often forgot about
yes the Pittsburgh Steelers the
Pittsburgh Steelers nobody ever talks
about their offensive line this unit has
been together for so long right opening
up holes for Le'Veon Bell or James
Connor we're seeing this year keeping
people off Big Ben doesn't matter if
it's the Jaguars the Ravens whoever it
may be he seems to have time every week
to let these aggressive downfield passes
kind of happen develop develop is the
word I was looking for that chappal
that's I protect you that's like your
offensive line and I'm about the same
size your number one offensive line
you've been talking about this line for
two years yeah and they're finally
getting some respect yes this New
Orleans Saints is the best o line in all
of football whether that's past
protecting whether that's big Andrus
peat pullin his big butt and legs that
look like they're filled with Turkey and
gravy around the edge to trap people you
know what else they're awesome at
getting out in the open and screen game
that's another huge part of the Sean
Payton offense but everything that they
do on offense is because of their old
lines down and then when you combine
that with how quickly drew can get the
boy
Kamara Ingram all those things that are
added to it yes that makes them almost
unstoppable I'm curious what you guys
think let us know comment section below
do you agree with Sims as oh
ranking I'm not gonna protect you here
I'm gonna SiC you to the comment section
and see what they think Oh No yeah I
know you're really afraid of the comment
section Thanksgiving is about loved ones
and family and I must say that we've
done a lot of somebody in left coast and
I love everyone that I've worked with
but there's one man that I just can't
quit so with three games on Thanksgiving
it is time to bring Ali back it's
Thanksgiving
I had to come home we've been waiting
for a very long time I've gone on a
number of bet dates and none of them
have worked out and I hear you've been
texting my producer your own game pics
you've been missing me too haven't you
yes let's just come in for the real
thing
what's coming for the real thing yes
really Ali's a good hugger here's how
this is gonna work okay I have three
games on Thursday three you win two of
them I'm back here next week
you win one you win zero we got to go
through this whole thing again where we
don't talk anymore I know I don't want
that you don't want that so let's start
off first game okay bears go to Detroit
bears are favored by three and a half
give me your thought process and your
pick this is game number one that's a
division game it is a division game he
ain't showed up yesterday boy did they
map Patricia did a good job against
Carroll mine yes he did I still like the
Bears first alley luck Owen bear second
game of the day Alex Smith is down Colt
McCoy steps up Washington in Dallas
Cowboys favored by seven and a half in
Dallas thank him a Dallas Thanksgiving
Day Jerry Jones sitting there going I
love that day I stop I love it too I
think that um I don't think that Colt
McCoy is gonna do good in the tech state
you okay I think so
Kovac Oy did beat the Cowboys with
Washington a few years ago but I
understand the bet I really do
so you're going Chi cago then you're
going Dallas last one Falcons go to the
Saints Saints are favored by 13
13:13 points yes in New Orleans in New
Orleans track me
I like the Saints like the Saints Ali is
going favorite favorite favorite bears
Cowboys Saints I'm gonna be honest with
you I probably would have done the same
thing I hope I'm back next week I like
it his three picks were the Bears the
Cowboys and the Saints all to cover
right what do you think well what was
the Bears spread three and a half
Cowboys was seven and a half Saints were
13 I like the Lions to cover it and keep
it close Wow okay then there's the which
one Washington is seven and a half point
dogs to Dallas I like Washington to keep
it close well what about Saints Falcons
that's what teen points I like it Lana
to keep it close so you're going against
ally in all three picks bring it dolly
there's only one Oracle around here I am
thankful for Ollie and because there's
our Thanksgiving episode I'm curious
what else are you thankful for well
first of all I'm thankful for you
there's good old friend the old town if
oh and thankful for name your handshake
oh but I'm thankful for a lot of things
my family the great life that we have
the people that work here at bleacher
report it's a special place and it's
really cool yeah I want to thank
everyone that works on this show you
guys are amazing I want to thank really
to be honest everyone that's a part of
this Simpson left go community that that
tweets at us and facebook comments and
Instagram comments and watches this show
you guys are amazing I know that we're
goofs and we talk about football every
week but we appreciate your support and
thank you to my favorite parents and my
family and my girlfriend eat'em and his
wife Danielle
oh you're thank you right you're reading
a lot of points here I told her I'm
trying to ask Jesus awesome thank you
guys so much you're amazing enjoy the
games on Thursday enjoy the games on
Sunday for Simms he's out homies I am
the lef koe man I thank you for doing
that every freaking episode guys you
don't have to follow it you guys know
that's it no more
[Music]
yes hello - it's a hole I would add even
more draft picks oh to trade to the
Raiders to get Khalil Mack again I would
spend more look I trade those flowers
that just fell over your name it's about
family it's about rekindling yeah it's
Chris Simms and sneezes hey what's up
homies thanks for watching subscribe to
the B our YouTube channel man you're
such a millennial also while you're here
we have a lot other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square
he ruined it it was really close